étranger
[Musique]
à la recherche de réponses
l'univers nous
rappelle
[Musique]
nous ton chef salut peux-
tu m'entendre chérie maintenant c'est un très
mauvais moment d'accord au revoir
je t'aime je t'aime je t'aime
c'est nouveau
[Musique]
whoa s'il te plait Etat  le nom de votre
monde natal euh premier chef de bienvenue de la
Terre
nous sommes les espèces avancées unies de
l'univers je pense qu'il y a eu une
erreur vous n'êtes pas le chef de toute la
Terre désolé pour la confusion commence
mémoire femme
moi
je suis le chef de  Terre pourquoi ta
voix est différente euh j'ai toujours parlé
comme ça depuis que je suis gamin ce que je
ne suis évidemment plus mais oui je dirige la
planète le procès de la Terre peut continuer euh
oh jusque là comme tu le dis sur Terre d'accord au revoir
je  je t'aime d'accord d'accord
tu parles de la communauté si
maman pouvait me voir maintenant je sais ce que tu veux
dire j'ai mangé ma mère à la naissance mais dans
les moments de grand succès je le regrette
c'est une chose pour ton espèce non juste
une chose pour moi tout le monde  a été choqué
[Musique]